trying to shine so that they can get
promoted yeah right no one likes that
person by the way right no one likes
the the brown noser yeah so
you know what that is that's making
those attacks that's your own personal
legal that's my own ego my own ego going
well that person just wants to get
promoted
if you can take a second you can take a
step back you can detach you can put
your ego in check
and if you do that
i'm actually happy
i'm actually happy if there's a person
working harder on my team that's good if
there's a person that's trying to
outwork me and do a better job than me
that's actually awesome if you keep your
ego in check then that's good you
realize that it's good and i'll tell you
something else and this is what i
answered this question
to
outwork me he's gonna have a hard time
he's gonna have a hard time outworking
me because i'm here to win too
you